apology video time how I'm gonna record
this video dude James Charles legendary
apology to Tati now with 47 million
views god damn up on its way to becoming
the most viewed apology video of all
time almost beating Logan Paul's so
sorry for my severe lapse of judgment 55
million views
I bet Logan is actually heard about that
dammit my apology video is number one
most people would be like ooh finally
people moved on to another cut I don't
know I'm just joking anyway yeah now I
think it's safe to say that people
didn't like this apology video not just
from losing I what is it now
over three million subscribers but for
having three million dislikes on the
video and I always say just come to me
if you need to make an apology video
just come to me so this doesn't happen
alright
when will you learn wait will you learn
so therefore we will go through what's
wrong with this apology video what's
right about it spoilers not much so
without further ado hi now James is
doing the classic I'm just gonna turn on
the camera and talk for eight minutes
which I can appreciate in the sense of
at least you know he doesn't have a
script
it's just speaking his emotions but at
the same time you have a lot of people
angry James you wanna be clear and
concise with what you're gonna say
generally if you want to get a message
across any message okay the number one
rule of information is the easier the
message is to say the quicker it will
spread right and to just turn on the
camera and bla bla bla bla bla bla bla
isn't gonna do that okay
I'm currently traveling abroad and just
woke up but I wanted to sit down and
make a video addressing all everything
going on right now okay so so far what
15 seconds in he said nothing that we
can already tell by just watching this
video alright you just woke up hey guys
I just woke up from my hair
can you tell even though I apparently
sleep with earrings on
so that makes no sense I owe everybody
an explanation but most importantly I
owe to important people an apology to
talk to you and James Westbrook I'm
sorry for everything that is going on
everything that I have put you through
over the past few weeks it looks like
he's about to sneeze what is that that's
great I love that god damn this who
speaks slowly again if you want the
message across you might want to be a
little quicker so he apologized to Tati
which in a way you know it's big of him
to do but at the same time it just
reaffirmed was kind of it everything she
said you know if you make it a mistake
apologizing is the right thing to do
without a doubt but if you made a
mistake with someone else when people
don't really know what happened to just
flat-out apologize seems to me like
everything they said was right I met
Tati and James
almost three years ago now when I was
first coming into the industry and when
I had no friends and nobody to talk to
or look up to and Tati very quickly took
on a parental role with me because she
knew my parents were across the country
and
over the past few not her family I think
another thing worth mentioning here is
that this video has more views than
taught this video so I understand that
he's trying to explain some context
behind the situation of how he met Conte
what if you don't know who Patti is it's
just so bad a lot of money most of my
career over the past few years has been
about me making mistakes and trying to
learn and grow from them and they
haven't always done the best job of that
hey James I guess we're not so different
you and I can't really be too harsh on
him okay always trying well try harder I
was really curious about James past
controversies because I don't know
anything about him but tachi said
something about it boil it all a scandal
and everyone was really afraid that he
was very toxic so what do you do this is
last year I can't believe we're going to
Africa today oh my god what if we get
Ebola James were fine we've gotten it as
sheep Oatley last year what we could
have gone to a shovel what let's keep
there's a lot of people watching me and
then a lot of people look up to me as a
role model and I hate knowing that I
disappointed not really them but most
importantly to people that have been
role models to me doing this
um I wish that I could say this is the
last time that I would make a mistake
that won't be what a train wreck yeah
you know if you're gonna apologize maybe
it's not the best to lead with I'm gonna
make more mistakes guys like before
anyone's even seen that you've made any
effort to improve I'm still gonna make
more mistakes guys this is just adding
more fuel to the flame at this point I'd
be lying if I said I'm still gonna make
some moves these guys I know that I'm
just the point people more and more as I
continue to learn and grow every single
day I'm gonna go very long way to go I
like how it seems like he catches
himself smiling there and then it's like
oh God
need to follow up with a pretty long way
to go here's where you say I'm still
gonna make mistakes
after you've acknowledged that you're
trying to improve not before Jesus
Christ and be the best version of me
that I possibly can be I'm know I'm not
perfect I'm still gonna make mistakes
so stupid I'm sorry in regards to the
coachella situation with the brand deal
on the security guard I've already told
my truth about this twice and instead of
talking about it for a third time and
explaining it and going into detail and
pulling up receipts it doesn't matter
it does matter James I've tried my best
to look into this drama I have no idea
what happened okay people don't know
what happened so you might want to
address it okay just because you've said
it twice doesn't mean that everyone's
already heard it okay clearly you have a
lot of new eyes on you here you want to
treat this video as if someone
completely new to you who's only heard
about you from this scandal and give the
context from there to say that you've
already explained it doesn't mean
anything
I
understand that no matter what I say and
then he follows it up with probably the
dumbest line you could say one of the
dumbest line I've heard in an apology
video I understand that no matter what I
say or do they're always gonna be people
that don't believe me and will think
that I am lying yes yes you're not wrong
but why God sir would you say that
that's like insulting these people that
you're trying to persuade in your
apology like you have all these new eyes
on you that are gonna look at you
extremely critically and to say doesn't
matter what I say you're not gonna
believe me anyway like yes technically
you're not wrong people are very riled
up right now and in a way it probably
doesn't matter that much what he says
but at the same time to say that it's
such a dumb idea there's plenty of
things that yes technically you're right
but to say that in this context is a bad
idea there's a bad idea James that's
okay at this point the truth really does
not matter even worse following about
the truth doesn't matter you're all just
so wrong about me then tell us tell us
people don't know they haven't heard you
talk about these things he talks about
how the boys situation where he has been
hitting on a bunch of straight people
he's been very public about this and
he's saying I wish I wasn't public about
it instead of saying I wish I didn't do
that he just says I wish I didn't tell
people I did that great idea boys have
been a topic that I've talked a lot
about
my social media journey and it's a topic
I wish I hadn't people think what you
did was wrong to say that you just wish
you didn't tell people about it instead
of I acknowledging that what you did was
wrong is really strange but
coincidentally enough talk to you really
once one of the people to set me down
and tell me how it looked from the
outside and let me know hey talking to
these boys might get you in trouble one
day and she was right in regards to so
he just brushed through the whole boy
situation without any acknowledgment of
that being wrong good job why why why
why are you dressing your mom is this
how he talks to his mom they don't text
each other they don't call each other
they just talk through his YouTube
channel no matter what if anybody is
saying or commenting or talking about
person anyway sorry I I know this is not
a laughing moment but it seems like he
wanted to run round this up on an
emotional part and bringing up your
parents when you've disappointed it's
obviously gonna hit anyone really hard
that's just how I interpreted this I
can't understand why else he would just
bring up his parents maybe to get some
sympathy I don't know it's really weird
an apology video should be to the people
you're apologizing here and then you're
an amazing mother
and I don't know what i'ma do without
you
well she clearly didn't do a good job
for me and the lessons that you have
taught me and and everything that you
continue to do for me and my brother I
need you to know that I need you to know
that all right okay chill out James and
the same thing goes for talk to you as
well who is an amazing person what goes
to Tandy I already forgot what he said
he speaks so goddamn slowly my god
don't waste people's time I feel I
watched it all at seven minutes it feels
like an hour and truly does want the
best for everybody around her I wonder
how many people actually watch the whole
thing I doubt many people did it's so
boring my god I'm so disappointed to
myself that I hurt her
end the video James some a lot of times
when I kind of address things in the
past oh my god I keep it on today out of
impulse and I've gone off that what the
hell is this how is this not an impulse
a lot of other times I got in drama I
reacted an impulse you uploaded this the
day after this video did nothing but add
more fuel to the flame you want to take
at least one day off for people to say
what they need to say about you so then
you can come in and also for you
yourself to kind of take in what's going
on and not just immediately going oh I'm
sorry
it doesn't matter what I say you're not
gonna believe me anyway and tried to
pull a receipt it's probably too dumb to
be able to do that anyway I know that's
kind of mean to say but Patty's clearly
way smarter than James she's got more
experience there's no way even if you
had the fact that he would be able to
pull that off there's almost he's just
admitting defeat at this point the video
goes on I can't I can't literally
actually not finish it here's the thing
this video did nothing now it's been a
couple days since it's been uploaded and
what's gonna be the follow-up he's
already said he's not gonna address
anything because people aren't gonna
believe him anyway so what is he gonna
do now people just added more and more
rumors and speculations because you
didn't address any of it and people are
very confused of what actually happened
so he can't come back and explain the
situation how is he gonna come back from
this I don't know and I think that's why
this is such a terrible apology video
and also literally all he had to do in
my opinion this if I was James Charles
the way I would have done it is to say
explain the context of your personality
change of you becoming this ugly figure
you can explain I'm very young I became
extremely so sex no not extremely that
would be gloating but I became very
successful very quickly and that has had
a very negative impact on my personality
and now that I've heard people around me
I realized that and then so hurt that it
took me this long to understand this
and then I'm gonna take some time off to
to focus on rebuilding these
relationship and saving these
relationships and also taking time to
focus on improving myself because I know
that's what I need to do now more than
anything I'm sorry to everyone that I
hurt and I'm sorry to everyone that I
disappointed at least then you said
these things you've acknowledged that
what you did was wrong and that you're
gonna improve and then when you come
back you have something to come back to
I don't know how James is gonna come
back from this I think this actually
could be the end I don't know he's still
so young however and people don't tend
to care about these things for too long
so I think he'll be fine but I think it
again another testimony of how you
express yourself in a controversy will
massively affect your career they could
make it worse or they could make it
better this one definitely made it worse
which is why you should come to me now
I'm joking about like oh you should come
to me about apology videos and that
might seem like I'm super calculative
about my apology videos I think luckily
I've been able to speak for in an honest
way and I think that also matters more
than anything but when you have so many
emotions going when you're in the middle
of a controversy like this it's easy to
get sidetracked and and confused about
what you're doing what do you think
about this apology smash like subscribe
if you haven't and I'll see you guys
next time
bye what you never played super
simulator you know it's fun right I'm
not supposed to give my opinion but give
it a try and then you can tell me if
it's
not convinced yet okay I'll cut you a
deal the game is available for free and
that's a great price
[Music]